john gartenheimer announcing he is
retiring as of today he is not going to
manage another game in the tigers
uniform it's a tough day it's a very
sudden and kind of jarring decision he's
really going to be missed a wonderful
man but you know health is number one
and tonight's starting pitcher for the
tigers is spencer turnbull spencer's
making his 10th start he suffered a loss
his last timeout sunday in chicago
banning third jose ramirez
right back up the middle and into the
glove of spencer turnbull a quick first
for turnbull six pitches and he's
through the top third of the cleveland
order tristan mckenzie going to make the
start for the indians tonight he will be
the nissan starting pitcher and
his very first start came against these
detroit tigers back in cleveland it was
a beauty and victor reyes on an o2
pitches aboard that'll bring up willy
castro the switch heading shortstop
he'll bant left-handed runner goes 3-2
pitch called third throw down it's in
time and they got him for a strike him
i'll throw him out double play chamber
candelario draws a walk on four pitches
castro wedding the two two
swinging a fly ball right center field
deep on the run is naked and it's over
his head all the way to the wall in
right center rounding third heading home
is candelario and castro because of that
hamstring is going to pull up at second
rbi two out double he crushed the ball
to the right center for your gap one
nothing tigers in the first well
turnbull has done a great job so far
through two he's retired the cleveland
team in order
well they finally get their first hit
and it's roberto perez smacks it right
back up the middle tigers are up at the
corners they're looking bunt from oscar
mercado another 3-2
and he rings him up
you can hear ryan blackney the home
plate umpire inside corner too close got
a swing kid
now the 1-0
line right back up the middle and hit
him on the hip
and the third baseman harold castro had
no play once he got to the ball so
they're loaded up with two down after
the infield hit by cesar hernandez and
you could tell him you can read his lips
i'm fine i'm fine and ramirez has
torched the tigers in his career
he gets it through the infield that's
going to drive home too roberto perez
scores josh naylor comes home and the
indians take the lead and look at
ramirez hustling into second base 2-1
try
we've moved to the fourth friend mill
reyes tyler naquin and roberto perez
against spencer turnbull who had a 33
pitch third that's when cleveland scored
both their runs but he's handled reyes
quite well second time that he's punched
out cleveland's big fella
turnbull strikes out naquin back-to-back
punch-outs to start the fourth for
spencer turnbull
perez sends one to right for daz cameron
started back now in
that's the way you do it after giving up
a couple in the last inning spencer
turnbull bounces right back haas goes
over to third ray is safe at first and
then at least extends the inning for
willy castro
got him looking at a breaking ball
borderline pitch he rings him up his
third strike out of the night and the
tigers strand
two here's oscar mercado
swung on and foul tipped into the glove
of eric haas second time that turnbull
has dusted mercato not the helmet's
fault kid
here's turnbull's pitch to francisco
lindor who lines it to the second
baseman and it is caught and a quick
inning for spencer turbo and another
good one back to back one two three
frame
six endings in the books the indians
have the lead on the detroit tigers
and how about the big man he's going to
go
4-2
here's the throw and it's offline he
goes in standing
with the lead-off double his tenth of
the year
lloyd mcclendon the acting manager is
going to come out right now and make a
pitching change yeah he's already
pointed
he's going to go to his bullpen spencer
turnbull overall a very nice night that
included a career best five one two
three innings daniel norris going to
take over now the 2-2 swung out and
missed good change big strikeout for
daniel norris in a big spot luplow has
been swinging the bat much much better
the last few weeks here's the 2-2 from
nora swung on and missed
sits him down
big big ouch for daniel norris
two to one indians eight thinning payoff
pits swung on hit sharply by the diving
paradise at third ball kicks off the
sidewall back into left field and a
double for lindor frankie lindor now at
third and indians at the corners one
down in the eighth and the indians best
hitter at the plate the 2-1
ripped right at candelario and the tag
is he got time to get him it was a
scramble
to get back to first base since cesar
hernandez
never found the bag the tigers have two
on here in the eights well let's see
maybe a hoss could do it again because
he had a little blooper his first time
up and now detroit has the same
opportunity here to
try to make something happen
3-2 back up the middle you go into
center field eric haas delivers and
stings his old club tied at two cameron
singled his last time up deal one the
other way
cameron comes through again tigers have
the lead as good room scores and haas
goes first to third back to back clutch
hits from the bottom of the tigers order
has surged detroit in front here in the
eighth inning bases are loaded two runs
in three two tigers and the 3-2
and he walks him in comes another run
he'll take it 4-2 tigers as haas crosses
the plate
fly ball to
right naquin has it
by the line throws on the run
and another he's home as cameron slides
in safely i don't know why carlos
santana cut that ball off
that good throw right down the line
perez the last hope for the indians now
the o2 from brian garcia
he got him
what an inning by brian garcia and what
a comeback win for lloyd mcclendon and
the tigers their 13th comeback victory
of the season